the weirdest place you've ever gotten
turned on
mine was jury duty i don't know what it
was about those
wow fluorescent lights
welcome to three-way blind date the
dating show where all the flirting and
get to know you mumbo jumbo is done
entirely through texting and
social media i'm kate your host and this
is rita
i'm from north carolina but i've been in
la for the past five years and i'm
hella excited to be here i work at ucla
doing peer-to-peer coaching
my passion is just promoting
loud americans in higher ed and getting
us
in mainstream media what are you looking
for in a person you ain't gotta be
passionate about
the same things i'm passionate about but
you gotta have some type of drive
well we have three winners for you today
i date uh
often i personally don't use dating apps
i think i've downloaded them all at one
point
i consider instagram my dating app i
don't date that much but i just got a
relationship
so that's why i'm here i talk to a lot
of girls but i definitely don't follow
through
here's how the show works we are going
to ask the guys some hard-hitting
questions
they are going to respond we have uh
code names for them where they are
currently
flip flop and flarp they will respond to
all of the questions we ask
on this screen we will be able to see we
will then analyze them and judge every
answer they have
to figure out what type of person they
are if it's someone you want to date
twist they are watching everything we
are doing ah
and you bright friend with you today i
do get
let's get into it first question for the
boys
take a picture of your shoes and send it
on over oh i just sent it to the wrong
person
not a picture of his shoes do you have
shoe thoughts i like a nice pair of
sneakers i feel about flip-flops they're
okay i mean it's not going to be like
a turn on for me sneakers turn you on
yeah i got sneakers
okay all right what one do you like the
best so far um i like the
middle one because they kind of like
remind me of my
my own shoes kind of wow looks like
someone's connecting with fly what up
flop what's going on on an immediate
level
club also has some high rise uh where's
the flood flop
oh we said we low key matching okay
do you ever like to go deep on first
dates yeah let me rephrase that
do you like to have deep conversations
on first dates yeah why not we're saving
like 500 hours of emotional labor you
know i mean
some of these questions that we've come
up with are the questions that you'd
want to ask on a first date but if you
were to ask you might be considered
crazy so this next question was a bit of
an ethics question
you're on a runaway train the train is
going straight and as of right now the
train's about to
kill three people you have the option to
pull the lever
veer off to the side and only kill one
person but that would mean that you
are responsible for that one person's
death do you let the train kill three
people and save yourself or
do you pull the lever kill one person
and be a murderer
either way you're a bad guy like i'm
just going for it full steam ahead no
that's messed up right
flop went ahead and said pull it so he
would sacrifice himself
to be a murderer oh boy we got a real
answer from flip
i don't usually consider circumstantial
ethics to be a good metric for morality
if i had to i'd have an easier time
killing one person
and living with it although it would be
terrible and this is why i don't
take trains damn flu i appreciate that
thoughtful answer what's going on fart
i'd derail the train save one person and
then have spider-man pull the other two
away with his webs i don't think flarp
got the question
at all but i like the world slurps yeah
you're creative what do you think about
these um
depends on the person right the type of
people you're going to kill
yeah i mean
all right guys she's at the bar twerking
up a storm and you want to go and strike
up a convo
opening pickup line i don't know dude
i'm not good at pickup lunch
what should i do that's a good pickup
line and it's larp coming in
hot with the pickup line l-o-l you read
it all right ready
i noticed you noticing and i wanted to
put you on notice
that i noticed more what you want to
leave this place and go to a cookout
hashtag north carolina hey i'm all for
it let's go it's a restaurant in north
go to carolina not to a cookout he knew
something exactly
flop you winning north carolina
what you know about that and flip is
shaking in his
boots take too long i've already gone to
the bathroom
flip and the time it took you to come up
with this opening line you guys have
been talking to this
pardon me ma'am
is that the end
pardon me ma'am i continue twerking
y'all but i love
cookout what do you think about flarps i
appreciate the long
pickup line okay floor if we're still
early in the game you can come back from
this
it's not looking great but you can turn
this around next question have you ever
sent an
unsolicited dick pic be honest
yeah you better be honest and if you
have send it now just kidding
can we do a two-parter to this question
have you ever sent a solicited dick pic
how do you feel about dick pics if i
didn't ask for it
right please don't send it to me have
you ever asked for one no
no yeah so you don't like dick like no
so far all we've gotten from flip is a
no
to the unsolicited and here we go a no
and then a yeah he's
sent a solicited dick pic flop said nope
to
unsolicited and for solicited he said
seventh grade was a wild
time hashtag tbt i don't know if a lot
of seventh grade girls are really
asking for dick pics call me crazy and
flarp
is coming up with an excuse
live fart he's beautiful bastard we got
slurp coming in hot with he sent a
picture of
comedian and civil rights activist dick
gregory dies
at 84. the only kind of dick pics i've
said and i'm pretty sure that's dick
cheney
i knew the flarp was a slow burn blaze
of glory right now he's on a hot streak
okay yeah you low-key funny we have this
bowl
social clues yes you want to know a
little bit more about their you know
social presence maybe learn what their
search history was or what their
first tweet was you'll pick from this
jar and you'll say which
person you want to answer all three
don't answer this one just who you want
to know more about
what is flop's first tweet his first
tweet was a reply to miley cyrus at
miley cyrus come to cape cod and blast
it
off with us seven years ago tweeting at
miley
okay to blast off all right with us
who's the us
i'm like a not so much miley fan now but
do i liked her in hannah montana and it
was nice
is it safe to say that this is putting
flop a little bit in the lead are sparks
flying with fly
yeah can you see them yeah
yeah flip the one on the left screen and
the middle
well who doesn't love an underdog story
am i right now it's time to turn the
tables and let the guys ask you a few
questions
first up we got flip coming in with a
question what motivated your interest in
social justice
okay that's a good question i grew up in
north carolina
my parents are from laos and thailand
growing up in a predominantly white
community
my my family experienced hella racism
sexism i didn't understand
that that wasn't okay i got politicized
when i went to unc chapel hill
started a women's uh women of color
empowerment sorority it's it's been
amazing and humbling to come from
that type of past in history right to
the point whoa
this is from flop okay slop's asking
what is your favorite part of living in
los angeles
and why there's so much culture
in l.a you can go to the beach any day
you can go
to any museum there's also always a lot
of education and art it's just so
beautiful you learned so much too much
leave this stage
you know we could always count on flarp
to keep it spicy over here
with the hot question ready here we go
when was your last one night stand
funny thing i've actually never had one
nightstand oh
so you wanna be my first one
[Laughter]
well what's happening
now we're gonna get into the
nitty-gritty questions that you have
prepared
i'll piss the torch i'll call to you
thank you
question number one if you could choose
a song to twerk to
what would it be and why you're really
into twerking yeah
do you like a guy who also twerks he
doesn't officially have to because i
will do the twerking on behalf of
us on behalf of yeah you twerk for two
okay so we got flarp i wouldn't twerk if
my life depended on it
but i could hit them folks with a dab of
ranch
i gotta be honest i'm having a hard time
getting my finger on
blurbs pulse to be quite honest i can't
really we got from flop
this is a no twerk zone but if i got a
we going
tip drill by nelly and we got flip
coming in with
london bridge by fergie because whenever
i think about twerking that song comes
to my mind
you gotta be open to twerking it's okay
if you tried and didn't like it
what'd you like no torque zone was uh uh
so you're gonna shame me for twerking uh
oh florp came back with a don't try to
emasculate it
escalator kissy face flarp you ain't
winning
by saying that oh my gosh things are
really heating up here
if a friend could describe you in a
hashtag
what would it be and why flop came in
with the hashtag
up for anything ochre
spontaneous if i can make a guess right
now i feel like flip
is in fact having a very hard time with
this question
if i know anything about flip we got
flip saying hashtag
drinks wine in the shower because
sometimes i drink wine in the shower but
i cover the bottle top so no water gets
in because i am also
classy
and then we got flarp coming in with
hashtag
flarpbite he don't bark
so he's all about action not a lot about
talking about it i would like to point
out flip is the only one who answered
the question
both parts of the question we got the
excuses rolling in from flop
then hear the and why is it did you not
hear it or were you not listening
what are three qualities you admire
about yourself
flip self-reflective self-critical
and communicative okay
we've got energetic happy compassionate
lightning bolt swirly star
flarp we got my height dashing good
looks and my scent
i love me nobody can do me better than
me
i am nobody nobody's perfect therefore
i am perfect flirt
y'all all right you know what i
appreciate about farp right now he is
doubling down he was like i don't see
myself winning did you like surrender
let me really double down we've learned
all that we could possibly learn
we've talked about twerking we've talked
about social justice how do you feel
about flip
i appreciate his thoughtful answers what
do you think
saying in terms of flip i'm also feeling
flipped
seems to bring that softness that i'm
able to listen and communicate and
listen to that entire question
yeah my only concern is maybe like funny
aspects and just like when we talk or
whatnot
you want fun as well as informed fun and
informed
in terms of flop i wasn't so sure if he
was ready to go
deep with me he was going strong in the
beginning yeah he was really strong i
appreciate the north carolina reference
that one was
pretty dope and then we move on to flart
you rooted for him
i was like you have you had a
cheerleader i'm still feeling there's
not
a thorough understanding of the type of
person that i see and a partner that's
hard because you can't really tell their
tone
and yes and it's hard to show your true
colors so
if you pick flip he'll be serious can he
be funny you pick flop he'll be funny
can he be serious you pick
flarp was the whole thing a masquerade
and he's actually really
a great listener and he's just being
silly right now because flarp is fun
he's funny
yeah you're absolutely right we're gonna
bring the guys in you're going to see
them all do you have the answer in your
heart
i think i have them the answer
i'm excited to see who she chose but
first let's meet the ones
she didn't choose first up let's see you
flirt
come on out
with the
i just want to say from the shoes it was
spiraling all downhill from the shoes
my actual name is brandon brown mark was
it was number one in my book but
you know what my book doesn't kill let's
bring out the runner-up
not the one chosen but still a contender
let's meet
flop oh
thank you
and that means if you don't know who it
is you weren't paying attention
we've got the winner the winner is flip
come on out
thank you candy voted
you voted i voted today my name is nice
to meet you
pleasure our day drinking your day
drinking yeah cheers
cheers that's been our show follow us on
a grant maybe you would want to date
them slide into their dms they're single
and they're recently rejected hey y'all
what's up
this is rita coming at you with some
updates me and jepta we didn't go on a
second date
unfortunately i made a goal to
go on one date a month for this year in
2018
i am now on date number two you saw
my interview questions if you think you
can tackle those questions you know feel
free to slide in those dms let's connect
let's do something
[Music]
hey unsolve this on a new channel i know
your partner subscribe here that was my
part